how are you doing today sir
i'm good how are you anytime i get to
talk to you is good
i have a million million questions and
not enough time
um i'm ready i'll try and be fast i'm so
i'm curious you've made like 190
projects or something crazy have you
ever thought about directed
yes i have thought about never directing
i will never direct a movie i have no
i think one of my strengths as a
producer is i'm not a frustrated
director i don't have any desire to
direct i would be a bad director
so it will never i can say definitively
on the record it will never happen
obviously you've been able to make so
many projects has there been anything
that you have actually
not been able to make for whatever
reason and why
oh many things i had a great script
uh called um
i think it's called the devil's bargain
it was it's about steve bannon
and it was a great script and i had
stephen frears directing it
couldn't get it made i've had a i've had
a book under option called stoner for 10
years
i think i'm actually going to get that
made but it's been 10 years so there are
a lot of things that i
that are that are that i've that i am
try i've tried or i'm trying to get made
that i've gotten a lot of no's on but
i always keep trying so it's so
interesting to hear that um
one of the things that i love about the
purge franchise
and especially this film is that you can
watch it as just a pure entertaining
movie
or you can talk about the subtext and
talk about what's really going on
and it addresses things going on in our
country can you sort of talk about that
aspect of these films
yeah we make you know my my always the
my priority the most important thing is
that our movies are really good
and scary and entertaining um and some
of them have messages in them and
have say something about the society we
live in and some don't
but no one ever hears your message if
your movie isn't good and scary
so that's the priority and the purge
movies in particular are movies that
each movie has something different to
say about um american society i think
the franchise as a whole has a lot to
say about kind of the american dream
and this new purge movie is no exception
one of the things about this franchise
is it came out i think the first one was
in 2013
and the country was in a certain
position and as these movies have come
out
it feels like the country is falling
apart more and more as each of these
movies
gets released have you sort of noticed
that do you agree
yeah the country is getting closer to
out to an actual purge i think we're you
know i think we're on a better track now
but uh
but i do think that is uh i i do think
that is true and i feel like james
demonico who's written all the movies he
directed the first three
he has a real ability to kind of foresee
the future
and kind of write about things that are
going to become issues in the future and
he's done that again with the forever
purge
as it relates to immigration um and uh
you know it's one of the great talents
that he has as
a writer director completely um i spoke
to frank guerilla not so long ago and he
mentioned that you guys have been
discussing maybe
having his character come back to
another purge film uh is that the case
um there were talks of that james has
said this is the last purge movie that
forever purge and he's done
but i have different ideas so i've been
pushing for uh for at least one more
so uh so yeah that that i i i don't know
if it would involve frank or not i can't
say for sure but if frank said that i
believe it
uh when are you guys going to be making
halloween ends
uh we're going to be making it uh
you know in the next six months we make
it our release date is a year from
this october so in 18 months so we'll
make it we'll start sometime in the next
six or eight months
and uh and i'm excited i'm excited about
halloween kills about our next halloween
it's
it's a pretty great movie i cannot wait
uh i'm obviously
also a huge fan of scott derrickson and
i'm very excited about the black phone
what can you tell people about it what
can you tease i actually just saw the
movie for the first time about a week
a week and a half ago it's definitely
one of the creepiest movies we've ever
done
um scott thinks it's his best movie
i'm such a fan of scots i'm i you know i
really like all his movies i love
sinister but i
but i'll certainly say it's one of his
best movies he and maybe maybe the maybe
the best movie he's ever made
i am so curious about fire starter uh
and this version that you guys are doing
um what can you tease people how has it
been going
uh it's been going great uh uh i have
there are no new developments except
that we're uh
we're uh the footage i love what what i
love what i'm seeing i love the dailies
i love what i'm seeing i'm very happy
with the job keith is doing
and uh and i think fans will be very
happy and i think stephen king will be
very happy
most importantly uh once upon a time in
staten island
uh that's something i've been waiting
for for a while when when is that coming
out when am i gonna see a trailer
you and i both you know we really got
derailed on that from uh
it's about it's about a movie in the
movie
theater and james really wanted that
movie to be seen in theaters in some way
or another
so clearly from the pandemic that got
sidelined it's one of the many projects
that got sidelined
but we've been talking about it a lot
internally and hopefully soon hopefully
but hopefully before the end of the year
i hope
i have to stop there i'm just going to
say congrats on this and seriously it's
always great to talk to you
you too youtube nice to see you again